china
with a 400 billion dollar iran deal
could deepen influence in the middle
east new york times story
the countries have signed a sweeping
pact that calls for heavy chinese
investment in iran for 25 years in
exchange for oil step that could ease
iran's international isolation
china agreed to invest 400 billion in
iran over 25 years in exchange for
steady's
supply of oil to fuel its growing
economy the deal
could deepen china's influence in the
middle east and undercut american
efforts to keep iran isolated
400 billion of chinese investment are to
be made in dozens of fields including
banking telecommunication port
railways health care and information
technology over the next 25 years in
exchange
china would receive a regular and
heavily discounted supply of iranian oil
the deal also called for deepening
military cooperation including joint
training and exercises joint research
and
weapon development intelligence sharing
key word
and intelligence sharing intelligence
sharing and iran has a lot of
intelligence
and this whole thing is going on while
iran still has
sanctions u.s still has sanctions
against iran that was imposed by
trump and they're still saying america
we're not worried about
you we're still going to do this 400
billion dollar deal with china what do
you think about it
this is scary as hell this should be
this scares you
you don't think about going around for a
vacation like i'm going to go to tehran
with adrian i'm good
i'm good on going to iran i'm good on
going spending any money in china this
is
incredibly scary stuff anytime that
china and iran are
talking about this kind of stuff you
know this is the lead story in the wall
street journal today the lead story
china's message to america we're an
equal now this is the lead story in the
wall street journal
so the the the time zone can you pull
that up
we're an equal now wall street journal
go ahead keep going i send it to you on
slack i believe kai i don't know if
that's uh i don't know if you can get on
the wall street journal right there but
um keep going just go back and type that
into search we're an equal now go ahead
go now
and i sent you it on slack if you need
to see that but look
you know it's something that definitely
i was aware of
um before i came to valuetainment a year
ago
and now that i'm acutely aware of is
china standing in the world they are
coming here it is right here
they are coming after america and they
are coming for the top spot
and you know their whole message here to
america when they sat down and they had
this meeting is
essentially like look what the hell is
going on in your country you guys are
freaking divided
you're racially divided you're socially
divided you're politically divided
we're unified yeah nobody can say
because if they do they'll get jack mod
but
um that guy right there pull him up he
basically
took i think 16 minutes uh scroll down
kyle you'll see it he basically
landed let me let me read that channel
again no no kai just go to exactly
china can already look at the world on
equal level he told the annual
legislative
sessions in beijing in early march a
remark widely interpreted in chinese
media as a declaration that china no
longer looks up to the u.s
the u.s routinely described china as a
strategic rival but beijing has rarely
if ever used such terms emphasizing
terms like win-win and cooperation one
of the more obvious
changes in chinese attitude is that
china now recognize the existence of
competition which was never
expressed in the past says uh wang and
advisor china state council and
president senator very interesting
very interesting and then they say um
kai can you just i think it's
maybe one sentence up or one sentence
down it was very intriguing
this part right here um competitive
leadership mr yang's warning in alaska
on taiwan's reunification is now
ominous uh uh in clink of how
competitive relations between the world
powers
and uh could lead to conflict the u.s is
committed to helping taiwan preserve
their
autonomy under pledges including the
1979 taiwan relations act and the biden
team trumpets
its plan to strengthen economic and
political links to type uh
taipei mr xi has made a reunification
with taiwan
which beijing regards as a breakaway
province a big part of his china dream
of national rival
chinese foreign ministry says mr yang's
anchorage warning the chinese side
pointed out that the taiwan issues
related to chinese china's
sovereignty and territorial integrity in
china's core interest it has there is no
room for compromise
kai go to the just top sentence i
believe that it may have been the first
sentence
they said something to the effect of um
it's the kind of
dialogue
basically the the whatever beijing
wanted to restore the kind of occurring
dialogue washington sees as a waste of
time says u.s and chinese officials
briefed on alaska meeting what point are
you trying to make yeah adam it was a
challenging over
basically the essentially just sort of
gave an overview of their perspectives
for years they just said
stay quiet keep it up guys they said
stay quiet don't
you know rock the boat a little bit you
know sort of their 2030 plan that
they've been planning and now that's
getting exacerbated because of the
pandemic and everything that's happened
and they're printing our money
and look message to americans message to
my fellow americans here
that's enemy number one okay that not
your
not if you're a democrat it's not the
republican if you're republican it's not
the democrat
you know i had a conversation with our
friend ricky the other day
and i assume a lot of people feel this
way uh i asked him who
who do you like more who do you like
more
joe biden or vladimir putin he goes oh
putin not even not even freaking close i
go hold on you're telling me that you
like
putin better than biden
an american what does that like mean
define leading like who you respect more
who you like more respect like who has
more power
who's smarter means wiser
fill in the blank american president
russian president who do you want
who do you sympathize that's a different
question that's my that's one question
yeah but my point is a lot of people and
and there's interviews like this all
over
where people would would say i i'm i'm
more into putin i don't know the correct
word here but i am more
sympathized with i don't think people
say that i i have to be careful
i don't i think you got to choose your
words carefully when you say this
because this is a very important topic
i think people think putin is stronger
and a better leader than biden but
people don't sit there and say i hope
putin succeeds
you think american people say i hope
there's i think there's a
segment of the republican wing that does
you are out of your mind i
also think there's a segment you cannot
just have said this listen i'm also
going to say this i think there's a
segment of the democratic party
that looks at trump as a worse person
than putin or even she
and that's ultimately my point is as
fellow americans are not your enemies
no i do know about that no i don't i
don't no no i i don't think that people
actually think
you cannot you mean to tell me american
people republican or democrat or
independent are rooting for putin
okay let me let me use this one let me
use this word correctly i think that
many americans
democrats specifically hate trump more
than they hate putin or she
and i think conversely i think a lot of
republicans
hate biden or hillary clinton more than
they do
that's different than wanting putin to
succeed
that's different than wanting xi to
succeed i would hope so but no no no no
that's different than wanting let's
listen
say pull our audience but but say that
say what you just said
okay let's say that exists tell me what
percentage of america
is actually the person you just
described what percentage of americans
actually if it's one percentage that's
what i need no no that's
one percent it's too many i would say
ten percent on both sides
no it's probably one percent both it's
probably one percent that says that but
that one percent is so loud that they
make you think it's 20
that's the problem with these guys
sometimes the complainers are so loud it
convinces the world
that they have so many people following
them they don't
it's a one per no it's not hope so it's
not well ultimately my point is this how
many
people i mean how many people in the
street how many people out there in the
streets okay
100 people you run into how many of them
are willing to rob your car right now
and take your money from you
out of 100 people one oh that's so what
are you gonna you're gonna judge
together 99 to 1
come on man i don't think we can do that
if but but to say they're they're fine
by the way
do you see the conflict that's going on
right now with russia and ukraine are
you kind of following that yeah over
crimea and all that yeah
so and you know us is you know with the
hopes of hey
if we support ukraine what could happen
with russia and russia gets involved
by the way just so everybody knows
russia right now so does u.s but russia
right now
has nuclear bombs targeted to every
major city in america that can get here
within 30 minutes
just so you know that 30 minutes it's
here we also have the same
same we have nato everything over there
yeah so do we
so do they but they got it within 30
minutes it's it's a very
uh is that new i mean that's been going
on it's not about it
but ukraine and russia look look look at
china and taiwan
how sensitive is that to china extremely
sensitive like number one
how sensitive is ukraine russia to
russia extremely
how sensitive is iran us with what china
just did
yes extremely sensitive you know what is
happening people are
disregarding the level of sensitivity
today so china's saying oh
okay u.s you're supporting this no
problem i'm going to support iran
by the way iran the people of iran have
no idea what this means there's a couple
things you have to think about with iran
okay
i haven't even come to you i'm sorry go
ahead so couple things about iran
so you have to know one part of iran is
sitting here saying what
okay so now we have china that's backing
us up and giving us 400 billion dollars
over how many years 25 years
so china's own china essentially owns
iran for 25 and africa by the way just a
little ps
out through africa in africa and africa
okay kai i sent you
a two links that if you can pull up one
of them was a couple things i just want
you to look at okay
one of them was the uh yeah go up a
little bit this is u.s allies go a
little lower
okay and then go to natural resources
which is a link prior that i sent you 10
countries with the most natural
resources okay
close it up close it up close up go back
go back to another link i don't want
them to see it i don't want them to see
it
can you tell me what country number one
has the most natural resources did you
see it or not did you see it or no
did you see what country in the world
has the most natural resources
if you're watching this right now what
country in the world do you think has
the most natural resources
what country i want you to actually
comment what country
in the world do you think has the most
natural resources it's around 24
trillion dollars
23.6 trillion dollars and it's not the
united states
i want you to guess it it's okay if you
want to guess it what country do you say
kai did you see it or no you know it sam
did you see it
what country think in the world just
throwing i'm guessing it's either the
usa or freaking china
okay us or china what are you going to
say natural resources
so you got a lot of countries in the
middle east that you think about right
uh they're
they're not on my list okay so let's
check this out a lot of people are
saying russia venezuela
it's on the list china sweden russia
congo iran venezuela all these other
things okay i'm going with china here
go to go to the list now go to the list
now
go up go up go up like keep going down
is what i mean
okay ten is australia okay nine is
congo good call by the way somebody said
congo eight is venezuela
14.3 trillion dollars worth of natural
resources united states
is seventh okay keep going lower keep
going lower
brazil sixth 21.8 trillion dollars
including gold iron oil and aluminum
uranium keep going lower five is russia
75 trillion dollars but they're five
four is india which they're going to
compete and india is
a u.s ally which is good news okay keep
going
three is canada it's a little concerning
with canada okay because
canada's got a better relationship now
with china than they do with u.s you'll
see here in a minute i'll show it to you
go to number two saudi arabia obviously
and number one
the most natural resources china china
tops the list for having the most
natural resources
estimated to be worth 23 trillion
dollars 90 of china's resource or coal
and rare earth metals however timber is
another major natural
genome the underserved zone china
producer uh and then coal
gold graphite lead the list goes on
right okay so now go to the other
link that i sent you to see what allies
this is many cus as their top ally i
wanted to find out what countries see us
as their top ally
wow israel's 82 but look at china
because this is a very important thing
to look at comparing
do me a favor flip the screen make this
the bigger screen us the smaller screen
sam if you can do that
flip us so they're seeing this more than
they're seeing us israel 82 percent u.s
one percent
china before meaning
yes 82 israel is a like better uh
ally with us than they are us versus
china u.s china and other countries
so whatever their other country it would
be notable south korea we're number one
look at where china is
four percent this is good okay
philippines
by the way look at china whoever who
else is four percent north korea is that
and and the other country named is that
is that ally or most name country that
people would make that
in this argument philippines 64 china is
nine percent
not even close japan 63 look at china
one this is good for us canada 46 i'm
sorry canada was which one's the one
that i said canada with china okay
canada wasn't
china it was another one no it was
another one i was making a comparison to
which we'll get
with uh you'll see where i'm gonna go
here with one of them okay so
canada 46 2 uk 14 australia 38
china six australia's neighbors were
china still six
kenya 35 china 30
brazil 32 to the u.s eight to china
nigeria 27 22 which you mentioned
earlier mexico look at mexico
interesting
27 and 16 south africa 24 and 19
india 21 and 3 meaning 21 is u.s
indonesia 16 6 argentina 15 5 lebanon
tunisia
look at turkey that's my concern that is
my concern
is turkey and you'll see where i'm going
with this go a little lower go a little
lower
go lower lower lower lower go lower
color i think there was one of the chart
here and then across
different countries both the u.s and
china emerged as key threats okay
mexico mexico you got it uh percentage
hussein
uh such and such country or group that
poses greatest threat to their country
okay uh mexico u.s turkey
u.s argentina u.s canada you see how
that works out okay canada that's the
one i was talking about
where china is ahead with canada as a
threat you see where that
but it's equal number here's the point
when you see this here
and you see what iran's doing with china
is doing with iran
right there's a couple things
there's a couple things that we are not
paying very close attention to here's
one of them
you have to know that if you can flip
the screen now i don't know if oh you
weren't able to do it look at the last
one
by the way us us three percent of the us
think we are our own
allies biggest enemy but he here's the
part you have to think about
if you can rush it you can close it up
kind just bring it to me so we can get
everyone's attention
so here's the part the challenge we had
3 000 by the way
the challenge we have now in the us is
the following in in
china is the following what people don't
realize is
those extremists in iran who are the
loudest people in the world
the 99 percent or the one person the one
percent the one percent
to their constituents how many
extremists does iran have low numbers
it's
it's they have a good number but meaning
they have them they have extremists okay
and they're sitting there saying wait a
minute
so imagine like the aoc of iran who's a
super extremist religious
leader all the way
i'm not going to say left or right all
i'm extreme religious that they're going
to sit there and say
wait a minute uh iran why are we doing a
deal with china isn't china
persecuting uyghurs is it is it
muslims have you seen what china is
doing to muslims wait a minute
are you trying to tell me money is now
more important than
our profit and are are you telling me
that that's more important
oh okay okay see what we're going to do
to you now
so what china doesn't realize they're
about to experience
is the following see folks i lived in
iran
when i lived in iran for 10 years you
know who was iran's number one enemy
us you know why because the extremists
in iran would say
hey shah why are you lining up with u.s
look what they're doing to our daughters
they're making our daughters not wear
clothes and not where you know what do
you call it
they're no longer conservative they're
not wearing the hijab you are making us
westernized and we hate you for it
what happened they eventually kicked
them out okay
the extremists in iran right now are
saying why are we lining up with
somebody that doesn't like our religion
why are we lining up with somebody that
sits there and tells the muslims of
china to go out there in front of camera
so they can track them and see exactly
where they're going
why why are we not why are you why are
you teaming up with them
so we are not going to see the side
effects of this
for at least five to ten years okay i
don't think you're gonna see the side
effects of this
for six months twelve months everybody's
celebrating right now oh we got this
on the other hand on the other hand why
is this deal taking place four months
after trump's not in office anymore
why why are they doing this deal three
months after trump's and what is the
january 21st whatever the date is what's
the last day trump was in office
is it the 20th okay why are they doing
it now
because they don't care they're not
afraid of u.s they're not sitting there
saying oh
the sanctions you have on iran let us
not do because biden's going to come
after us they're saying dude
we're going to do the deal and there's
nothing u.s or biden's
going to do about it here we go and
their first business i may be wrong
this deal has been in the works for a
while now it's not like it just came up
yeah but it just got done no right okay
okay i agree with you guys
400 billion dude is getting done now so
now you're seeing the deal getting done
how much was u.s gonna pay iran to part
of the nuclear deal 150. it was 150
million
150 billion so this is 3x that give or
take here i'll throw a couple things out
at you you know when i when i look at
these numbers from the story
you know everybody looks at 400 billion
dollars and think that's unbelievable
but if you amortize that over 25 years
it's not that much
25 years though that they have them
under their thumb is unbelievable and
that's what china does
and when i when i saw that data that you
put up over there and i saw
mexico list china as a 26 percent their
number one alley
ally i had no idea they even thought of
china as even a remote
allies exactly and that is what china
does
that's their diplomacy they throw all
kinds of money into countries they build
up their infrastructure and then they
own them
i mean could you imagine if china had a
huge presence in mexico
that is a very very big problem for the
united states and here's my question
when you see all this and
you hear iran you hear china you're you
know all these threats and all the scary
talk about it but
what do you guys think is the end game
for a china
foreign iran it's economic dominance
isn't it not so much iran but for china
they want to be the number one economy
this isn't a warfare
type thing where they want to come in
and take over this country i don't think
isn't it where they're just trying to
become the most dominant
country on the planet no questions so
think about it this way who has an
advantage the person that's dominating
right now or the most ambitious
person behind closed doors that's
monitoring how you dominated for the
last 50 years for me to study all the
right wrong inner mistakes
exactly what china's doing who is got
the edge
china does and china is exploiting
that edge that they've had watching
exactly what u.s has done and look at
them now okay
and by the way this isn't just about
made in china 2025 we're going to be the
largest you know most powerful regime in
the world
this is influence control and it's long
term it is not short term and if they do
take over
they're going to be imposing think about
it this way you know how they said if
germany would have won everybody in the
world would have been speaking what
language
german right oh hitler wouldn't want a
german everybody would have been
speaking german right
okay well we know what happened we all
speak what
british english whatever you want to
call it we speak english right okay
but what else has u.s imposed to people
around the world hey
uh mr gorbachev please tear down that
wall
you know hey what you guys need
communism yugoslavia you need
capitalism hey china what you guys need
to do is you need to let your people
own business and be capitalists hey uh
gorbachev
the problem that you have in your
country is everybody drives the same car
everybody drives the same calls let your
people compete so these people say well
that's a great idea we're gonna we're
gonna take capitals them on
but guess what china's gonna do now
they're gonna go and post
their philosophies and what's one of
their philosophies silencing you
silencing you their philosophies is no
philosophies
their philosophy is their way or the
highway
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you